welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul aka the guy whose puns
make you rue the day you found the
channel and this video we're breaking
down season two of euphoria the ending
has a lot to unpack from it and
throughout this video we're gonna be
going over the full season and talking
about what we took from the final few
scenes i want to get straight into it
but full spoilers ahead so if you
haven't had a chance to check it out
then i highly recommend that you check
out now make sure you hit the thumbs up
button and also subscribe for videos
that have the crown jewels of bad jokes
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into euphoria
okay so euphoria has had a bit of a
weird release schedule and due to the
pandemic there were several setbacks
season one released all the way back in
2019 and it's been a long three years
waiting for this one to drop we finished
that one up with re-relapsing after
jules left her in order to go off to the
city the aftermath of this was explored
in the specials and we pick up this
season with rue accompanying pheasant
ashtray to a drug deal for the first
part of the video i'm going to be
breaking down everything that led up to
episode a but if you just want to see us
talk about the finale then time codes
will be linked below now due to ashtray
killing mouse they have a new supplier
who forces them to strip to check for a
wire this is somewhat murdered in the
finale when they attempt to shift blame
after kirsten tells them the police
found a body it's a really gripping
introduction and instantly you realize
how much of a dark path that roo is on
inspired by the woman that's running the
show she slowly wants to change the game
and become a dealer herself alongside
this storyline is cassie who ends up
hooking up with nate at a new year's
body that goes out with a bang couple of
bangs to be fair and the problem with
cassie is is that she's the best friend
of nate's ex maddie hey they won a break
because of this there's a tense scene
where she hides out in a bathtub whilst
maddie comes into the bathroom she and
nate were just making out in and i kind
of hope that she was holding her breath
because it stunk like [ __ ] now cassie
has a lot of unrequited love for nate
and early on their relationship takes a
lot of focus hate also has to deal with
his father cal and the recording of him
and jewels concerned that he could get
out he ends up going straight savage and
he brandishes an unloaded gun at maddie
after the beating that bez gave him
there's a lot of talk about brain damage
changing his personality but to be fair
the guy was always kind of a douche add
to this cal lays it all out literally
and we see nate start to become darker
than most of the cinematography in the
series in a strange twist of fate though
it could end up ruining everything his
father had built he gives the recording
to jewels to let her do what she wants
jules destroys it but come the end of
the season we learned that nate had
multiple copies of it and that he handed
them over to the police now in rue's
life she meets the duplicitous eliot and
she and jewels confront their past
decisions elliot is a massive enabler to
rue and he basically manipulates their
breakup by telling jewels about roo's
addiction so that it can cause issues
with the pair whilst this is going on
roo has the terrible idea to become a
drug dealer herself and she secures a
suitcase full of them to sell jules then
tells rue's mother that she's using
again and this leads to a major
intervention in which the suitcase is
flushed he's urged to go to rehab by her
mum again which he's hesitant to do as
the drugs are a crutch in lifeline as
toxic as that is in addition to this
she's always used jewels as a support
mechanism but she ends up exploding on
the character she also reveals the truth
about cassie and nate and yeah i don't
know why there was such a big problem
because hey like i've said they were
technically on a break now unable to pay
the money back from the suitcase the
softly spoken dealer locks her in a room
and dopes her up with morphine luckily
she escapes though and she reconciles
with ali who she finally accepts help
from now this kind of takes us into
lexi's play which betrays nate in a
negative light due to lexi being
cassie's sister he dumps her and fez
doesn't have that good of a time either
discovering that the police are close to
unearthing the truth about mouse the
cracks start to show and that takes us
perfectly into episode 8. opening up
fezcos custer tells them the police
found mouse's body and though fate
initially tries to shift the blame
ashtray kills him in a move that mirrors
the murder of mouse bezko was on his way
to lexi's play but the lifestyle choices
that he's led means he doesn't get to
attend or be brought into the overall
show of it metaphorically the play is
very much retelling the events that have
happened in the seasons and what they've
cost titled our life the characters in
many ways are forced to confront their
happiest and darkest moments and this
leads to them either being better off or
going down a darker path now this is
very much reflected in aid who of course
dashed off last episode he ends up
exposing his father and though it is
somewhat of a positive path for him it's
very much bittersweet cassie returns and
as the play starts to shift into its
third act the show does too and cassie
belittles her sister in front of the
entire audience there was of course a
brilliant scene last century in which he
broke down in front of a mirror before
putting on a facade and smiling like the
joker she returns empowered by the
embarrassment and confronts her making
the play even better it was already
broadway level especially for a high
school production and now it's a true
tour de force now on stage the pair
fight it out which of course highlights
the drama that's in their real lives
being stranger than fiction the cherry
on top comes when maddie calls out
cassie for her dating nade behind her
back even though like we've said they
were on a break now at this point
everything kind of blows open much to
the audience's delight they of course
represent us finding entertainment in
people's misery and the entire thing
becomes farcical with us getting a royal
rumble whilst everything goes off as
maddie chases cassia the auditorium the
show continues and initially it gets
played off as being all part of the act
now this is important as due to the
stylistic choices of euphoria it of
course often goes from sincere scenes to
full-on music videos and because of this
it's very difficult to tell the
difference between what's performative
and what's real this is very much
reflected in the play which becomes
somewhat a piece that blurs the lines of
reality between being art and what's
happening to the characters it's high
level commentary on how people end up so
wrapped up in their own drama that they
eventually end up doing things to
heighten it so that they become
important lexi of course very much felt
like she was in the background and
though she created the play to somewhat
allow her to be at the forefront however
she wasn't really ready for the real
life drama that came with it it
perfectly surmises the show as a whole
and how things are often glamorized to
stop the characters from seeing the true
ugly face of them rue became a drug
dealer because she was captivated by the
idea of being a quote-unquote female
boss however she saw that the true side
of this was dark and depraved and much
like the play just wrapped up in an
illusion lexi later says that she wanted
the play to go a certain way but that
it's been ruined which very much sums up
the lives of the characters they all had
these amazing visions of what their
goals would turn out to be but they
pretty much never happened that way and
their lives were ruined much like the
piece now rue then spots elia and
recalls a couple of days earlier when
she went to him and said that he might
have accidentally saved her life he
busts out a song on the guitar like we
used to have dream of doing in high
school to impress girls and then asks
her a truth or dare question he asks if
they can still be friends and no we
don't get an answer the pair nodded each
other in the auditorium back behind the
scenes alexi commits to delivering the
finale spurred on by the fake versions
of those in her life she's very much
tied into the fantasy peru gets a chance
of her name going which spares her on to
step out from behind the curtain back
with beds and co he realizes that the
police are coming and tells ash to
surrender so that he can stay behind and
take the fall it perfectly brings the
opening of the season full circle and
though things don't go that way in the
end it shows how much fez cares about
ashtray and how he very much takes
responsibility for the life he let him
into ash doesn't listen though and he
grabs all the guns he can in order to
face down against the swat team now this
idea of someone facing things head-on
with a gun that leads to police
intervention is murderer nate who rides
out to his father with a revolver in
hand yes kyle if he's found the
happiness he was constantly searching
for and says that he's realized they
both get off and hurting people they're
as destructive as each other and though
nate could have given his dad a way out
he reveals that he kept copies of the
video and has tipped off the police
throughout we've seen flashes of him
having dreams of his dad sexually
assaulting him and if you recall the
first season had a scene about him
discovering carl's tapes on one he made
a man call him daddy which has clearly
affected nate his entire life his mother
was baffled by the change in him because
he was such a happy boy but he became a
dark and vengeful kid after this moment
this entire thing very much reveals how
cal defined his life and though he says
he doesn't think his dad will ever
change he does they could have shot and
killed his dad but instead he called the
authorities even though it would ruin
his father's reputation
and make his business impossible to
inherit he manages to walk away but
unfortunately ashtray doesn't he ends up
firing at the swat and accidentally he
shoots fez who gets blood all over the
ladder that he had for lexi after
bullets rain down on the bathroom ash
ends up playing dead and though he takes
out one of the officers the others don't
let him live as she's shot and killed
and it's by far one of the most tragic
stories in the entire show now from here
we jump back to rue's eulogy for her dad
this ends up being brought across into
the play and alongside this we see the
final moments in which lexi and cassie
visited their father in hospital this is
accompanied by the first time ruo deed
and lexi visited her in the hospital
this shows how these two moments of her
being forced to take care of everyone
has also made her bear the brunt of
their trauma because of this though lexi
is always there to listen and support
people and we get an awesome scene in
which she and rue find common ground in
the bad times that they've faced now
after the final scene of the play jules
finally finally finally reconnects with
roo she tells her that she loves her but
rue doesn't say back and instead she
kisses her on the forehead before
walking out the theater it's very much a
sign of her saying goodbye and it's
unlikely that the pair will ever
reconnect again in the closing monologue
we hear rue say that jules was her first
love and there's a lot of emphasis on
the was she tells us that she stayed
sober for the rest of the year and that
she only thinks jules was the first love
because she was high for most of their
relationship it's a very empowering way
to close her the season and she states
the words of ali who said the thought of
being a good person is what kept her
trying to be a good person now this is
important as it's also what kept her
sober the thought and meaning of being
sober is what kept her in line and it
was actually easier than returning to
the drugs because it meant more for
herself and those around her to stay
clean this kept her on the right track
and in the end it's an awesome way to
close out this arc for the character the
feeling of actually achieving sobriety
was more powerful than the high from
drugs themselves and she's finally found
acceptance and managed to step away from
the toxic things in her life whereas
season 1 culminated with jewels leaving
rue rue has now left jewels and she's
escaped the toxic cycle that the pair
were trapped in much like the first
season we close out with zendaya singing
a song but whereas the last time it was
tragic this time it's very uplifting
it's a great way to close out the season
and the episode itself now before we get
into the review part of the video i've
dropped the winners of our february
competition on screen right now we're
going to be running another one this
month to give away some blu-rays but i
haven't had a chance to pick them out
yet because i only realized today that
it's the end of the month but if you
want to get locked into that yet if you
want to win this prize that you don't
know what it is then just like the video
comment below and make sure you
subscribe and sell me your soul haha
gotcha now as for how i feel about the
season i thought that this one pretty
much improved on the first one in every
single way the storylines editing and
general grungy book glittery feeling are
ramped up and it elevates the show to a
lot of new heights now what the series
does is that it perfectly portrays the
dangers of addiction but it does this
beyond just drugs and shows it in almost
every single character along with rue
narcotics you have cassie who's addicted
innate cal who's addicted to sex and so
on and so forth we really watch the
characters as they pretty much destroy
their lives due to this addiction and
though a lot of the stories feel
unconnected they weave this thread
throughout everything really well now on
top of this are the incredible
production values that the show has the
cinematography and editing are next
level and often at times the show
spirals off into what feels like it
could be a music video at the end of
each entry i went on google found the
songs used in every episode and ended up
just listening to them on their own
because the music choice is next level
they also do a lot of stylistic things
that help make the story a complete
blast to get through the first entry
opens with a pheasant ashtray origin
story that shows us not only how the
ladder got his name but also how they
got in the game the grandma is barely in
the season but she makes such an
impression early on because of how well
this is all put together episode 4 as
well does an excellent job in its
opening showing us what ruined jewels
think their relationship should be like
we get parodies of ghosts titanic snow
white brokeback mountain and a lot more
it just elevates the shade in new
heights but i do have my criticisms too
i think that the way that the series is
put together with a heavy reliance on
narration can be a bit of an issue at
points we kind of jump around a bit too
much at points and it can lead to stuff
feeling just like a montage instead of a
distinctive scene the specials were
great at just keeping us locked in the
moment because they didn't really have
the ability to jump around and sometimes
that frantic feeling can be a bit
detrimental now that is a minor
criticism and i do think that the
performances here really stop it from
falling into just feeling like we barely
get any time with the characters the
actors let you know who the characters
are with very little because their
performances are just so captivating
euphoria on the whole is that too and
though i have my nitpicks things work
really well to tell a story that you
just get lost in there's search it on an
atmosphere to it where it just feels
like a piece of art at points and all in
all i don't have that many bad things to
say about it the overall show is as
psychedelic as the subject matter and it
works on pretty much every level for me
even if you don't like the story i think
the way it's produced still keeps you
engaged and this was another brilliant
season all in all really enjoyed our
return to the world of euphoria and it
gets a 9 out of 10. i'd of course love
to hear your thoughts as nine is a
pretty high score and i know people are
going back and forth on it make sure you
leave them in the comments below and if
you want something else to watch we have
a full breakdown of peacemaker linked on
screen right now and also another video
for your punk ass hopefully i see over
there and with that other way thanks for
sticking through this video hope you
enjoy the rest of the week peace i'm out
peace